in der wahlnacht hatte man den eindruck
dass so biden selbst geschockt war von
dem ergebnis oder den bisherigen
ergebnissen und prognosen hochrechnungen
die man gesehen hat also ging auf die
bühne und und wirkte also ein bisschen
als wenn er neben sich stehen würde
seine frau stand ja bei ihm musste immer
noch was ins ohr flüstern weil er
vergessen hatte vielen aus seinem
wahlkampfteam zu danken und den wählern
zu danken also da merkte man richtig da
war ein mann konsterniert das sei jetzt
gestern abend schon deutlich besser aus
was mich schockiert nele sind die bilder
die wir sehen unser kollege max kiewel
den wir da in pennsylvania jetzt vor dem
rathaus sehen die nationalgarde die auf
gefahren ist jemand das sind bilder nach
einer wahren in amerika das erinnert
mich irgendwie an weißrussland und
beobachter müssten demnächst dann auch
ja aber wir sehen und es ist
weißrussland soll das ist amerika in
weißrussland wird demonstriert in
anderen ländern wird demonstriert aber
das sind das sind staaten mit mit
despoten an der macht oder in der
regierung aber hier geht es um amerika
und trotzdem ist die stimmung so
aufgeheizt dass der rathäuser von der
nationalgarde geschützt werden müssen
also da ist im vorfeld oder nach der
schließung einiger wahllokale wirklich
sehr sehr viel schief gelaufen
das ist echt bitter ja auf jeden fall
und wir haben sehr geehrt maxi wird das
weiter für uns beobachten wir wollen wir
noch einmal zurückkommen zu joe biden
du hast das gesagt bei seinem ersten
auftritt seine frau muss dem dann doch
noch mal was ins ohr flüstern und leider
muss man ja sagen das ist auch das was
vor allem seine gegner immer wieder
gegen ihn nutzen ob er in seinem alter
wirklich noch auf der höhe ist er
vergisst viel bereden verquatscht der
sich mal weiß nicht genau wo er mit
seinen sätzen hinwil und dort gibt es
besonders zwei ausschnitte die wir ihn
noch einmal zeigen wollen
die ganz besonders diskutiert werden
es ist so breit wie hoch das ist michael
dorner
[Applaus]
es muss konstant
wer probleme mit namen beim ersten
stellt er seine familie erstmal nicht
ganz korrekt vorbei vor allem das zweite
video war das was extrem diskutiert
worden ist denn er sagt noch mal vier
jahre george offensichtlich wir hatten
zwar schon george mehr als einmal als
präsident aber jetzt gerade nicht
das ist schon ein übler fauxpas
eigentlich das wäre quasi so als wenn
jetzt ein herausforderer von angela
merkel plötzlich von petra sprechen
würde
zwölf jahre oder 16 jahre petra sind
genug und jeder würde fragen was wer ist
petra also das wirklich das mag ein
fauxpas sein aber es ist es gibt
natürlich eine reihe von dingen jetzt
und es ist über den gesundheitszustand
von joe biden ja schon lange lange
spekuliert werde donald trump hat das
selbst auch gemacht und die frage die
man sich stellen kann ist natürlich und
das ist ohne jede häme und das ganz
neutral formuliert ist ein 77-jähriger
noch fit genug um präsident der
amerikanischen von von amerika zu sein
das ist eine wirklich wichtige frage
da muss man wahrscheinlich auch
tatsächlich bei beiden das dann über
fragen weil du hast gesagt donald trump
sagte mal wieder ist so klug er selber
nicht mehr die jüngste also nein als
mitte 20 denkt man sich so ist sind wir
ja bei alte weiße männer das einzige was
man da hat man muss ja sagen also es
gibt menschen die sind mit 85 mit 90
noch topfit und das ist ganz ganz toll
aber es gibt auch menschen die sind ein
bisschen jünger und sind nicht mehr ganz
so viel das ist einfach die natur und
die frage ist wenn man präsident der
amerikanischen von amerika mehren möchte
dann muss man hat man so einen großen
druck mann ist in so vielen sitzung
wir müssen denken an g 20 an g7-gipfel
wie lange wird da verhandelt wie lange
wird er hart verhandelt wie lange muss
man auch voll konzentriert bleiben also
angela merkel beherrscht ja genau das
auch die nacht sitzungen und da muss man
dann schon glaube ich bei joe biden mit
einigen zweifeln zur kenntnis nehmen
möglicherweise hat er diese konstitution
nicht mehr und das ist natürlich ein
schweres problem für ein land was eine
führungsmacht in der welt ist ja er
selber sagt er ist auf jeden fall noch
fit genug das wird sich dann nur zeigen
wenn er tatsächlich dann heute
hoffentlich dann beim ergebnis als
präsident aus der ganzen wahl
herauskommt privat natürlich noch immer
auf einige bundesstaaten die ganze sache
ist weiterhin hoch spannend aber hoch
nervenaufreibend
und das natürlich auch für die
wirtschaft denn wer der nächste
präsident der usa wird hat auch sehr
viel einfluss darauf und genau darüber
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit einem
wirtschaftsexperten und zwar ist mir
professor gabriel feldmeier nun
zugeschaltet guten tag sagen sie uns in
ihren augen gibt es einen der beiden
kandidaten der für die weltwirtschaft
auf jeden fall die bessere wahl wäre
alle kein ton dafür diese sehr sehr
wichtige frage aber du bist ja noch bei
mir gibt es ein von beiden wo man sagen
kann er setzt sich entweder mehr für die
beziehungen ein jetzt nicht nur dort
chance sagt natürlich america first und
das muss wahrscheinlich auch jeder jedes
staatsoberhaupt für sein land so sehen
aber für wen ist es auch wichtiger gute
beziehungen nach deutschland auch europa
ins asiatische ausland zu haben
gestern direkt getwittert nachdem die
amerikaner oder nachdem amerika hat ihr
ausgetreten ist endgültig aus dem
klimaschutzabkommen dass man in 77 tagen
also direkt am tag nach der inauguration
wenn joe biden dann möglicherweise
präsident ist so hat so beiden das
zumindest formuliert direkt wieder
eintreten wird also es gibt von joe
biden schon das bestreben internationale
verträge doch wieder stärker anerkennen
anzuerkennen und sie auf einen auf ein
höheres niveau der wichtigkeit so heben
als das bei donald trump also
internationale verträge sind ihm wichtig
aber die frage die du ja auch zu recht
stellt wie gut wäre joe biden eigentlich
für deutschland also wie viel trank
steckt eigentlich in beiden das ist
schon in der große frage und dann glaube
ich sind viele bundesbürger er etwas zu
euphorisch und dazu optimistisch denn
joe biden ist beispielsweise jemand der
auf protektionismus setzt also das thema
zelle wenn wir über über den zollstreife
den usa sprechen dann wird uns der
sicherlich auch unter einem präsidenten
joe biden noch länger noch einmal
nachfragen wir sind bild und wir liefern
dir deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren